Một ngày 12,5 năm, không ăn xa khả đối vạng,
cảm au, tiếp nhận tin bảo của mình rất về việc,
phát hiện một thi thể nữ dưới vương tục tại át tham.
Ngay khi nhận được tin bảo, không ăn xa những trong có mặt phong toa,
bảo vệ hệ chung và bảo cao con hành tình.
Khiểm tra bàn đầu, xa định chiến của nạn nhân có vết thương so với rất về ra,
có giấu hiệu bị rất hại và nếm xú đừng tốt của mình rất tại cạnh đường biết tôn kinh lâu một át tham.
Sau mình bàn đầu, nạn nhân là em vế tế mở cá,
xin năm 2018, 1 xa phút tình, cảm au,
qua ra xa khả 1 quanh hiện của nạn nhân,
có quanh kính rất đều trà sát định gí càn là hộ an kịch,
xin năm 2018, chú xa tên tình bếng lắm.
Tạm chú xa cái đối vạng đang làm tuyệt cho một chú tổ cá ở địa phương.
Tại các quan công an, kỳ đất hành tình tình bộ hành bi phạm tổ.
Huyện vụ an tiếp tục đều trà.